hello ladies and gentlemen I'm Greg and
I'm John welcome to movie news of the
week this week februari 20th through the
25th breaking news from a few days ago
matt reeves is confirmed to be directing
the batman men athlete left the
director's chair mat recept in then he
apparently left again and now he's
officially on board that raises directed
such films as Cloverfield Let Me In dawn
of the planet of the apes and he's
currently working on post-production for
war for the planet of the apes or what
photo well let's hope that movie goes
well or else he might be kicked out of
directing the Batman because of what
happened to Ben Affleck oh no that
wasn't confirmed maybe the Wonder Woman
villain Ares might be played by david
few lists yeah I really like David
Thewlis and the Harry Potter films and
the Fargo TV series the dragon heart I
think he can make a great Wonder Woman
villain totally because if i'm not
mistaken ares it's supposed to look like
a pervert Shane Black's predator has
revealed its first cast photo this week
Shane Black also confirmed so we'll be
rated R and quoted directly as saying
pg-13 is for [ __ ] spines bleed a lot
total woman once a month end quote
guillermo del toro confirmed that
Hellboy 3 will in fact not be happening
I'm really bummed about that I wanted
him to make a trilogy well in the words
of the great rapper Dom Kennedy if it
don't make money it don't make sense
jay-z says i don't know i only listen to
white rappers the best to the best simon
kinberg the man who co-produced and
co-wrote several the previous x-men
films will make it a directorial debut
directing the next x-men film reports
state that it will be focusing on the
Dark Phoenix storyline which Simon
Kinberg wrote about back in two thousand
six
no no not that one now we have hope
martin scorsese's highly anticipated new
films the irishman which sees the
legendary director reteaming with actor
robert de niro and potentially stars
like Al Pacino and and Joe Pesci is
coming to netflix yeah that's great
because why would I want to watch this
movie on the big screen you know I was
hoping that this was going to be a
sequel to one of my favorite movie
Righteous Kill also starring John
Leguizamo and Curtis if you said Jackson
but you know what Greg I think this will
be a nice way to round out my triple
feature you know Netflix and chill night
along with you know the do-over and the
ridiculous six those are bad film news
broke this week that drew goddard the
writer behind a lot of really cool [ __ ]
from TV and the movies is going to start
working on the deadpool two scripts well
it's really a new yeah i'm happy about
that i should i just seems like a good
man joe carnahan the man who director
wet John Humphrys favorite movies the
gray is gearing up to direct bad boys
three is working on the raid remake it's
scripting the uncharted movie it is now
supposedly the writer for the new
x-force movie you know cuz why give it
time to relax his mind and you know work
in an organic taste anyway I say pile it
on because the last thing I care about
is good quality filmmaking thanks
Hollywood Warner Bros announced that
they're developing a Nightwing movie
being held by the director of the lego
batman movie that man will be Chris
McKay now DC movies have not been very
good lately and and a lot of the reports
coming off said do not inspire much
confidence either yes but John we can
ignore all that as long as they keep
announcing more movies yeah yeah I like
the best way I like to go into a movie
is Think You I maybe this time it'll be
good always next I always next time DC
hey jurassic world to started filming
this week that's right just take a look
at this photo posted on twitter by bryce
dallas howard this is exciting because
everyone's favorite part of jurassic
world was Bryce downtown I'm just saying
if you're going to tease a
behind-the-scenes photo I could not have
asked for anything more than this
director speed with bright dog collars
character name on it yeah you know just
a character that we all remember you
know she's well written everyone knows
her name he say what's Bryce Dallas
Howard character named Jurassic world
you immediately go oh Claire Karen
Claire get david cone on this is not
really adding into the patient alright
geeks that's it for movie news of the
week I'm Kristian harloff I'm Mark Ellis
tune in next week to smooth know when we
do more movie news of the week just
kidding on the real reason the real
reason to what some of you might not
believe me when I first said
[Music]